Fallen Fruit began in 2004,...
...and what we did was we mapped the neighborhood between our houses...
...for all the fruit trees that exist in public space.
What we've learned is that over 100 trees existed within five city blocks...
...and those trees gave organic fruit all year long.
What we're really interested in is how you walk through a neighborhood...
...or how you might experience something in a different way.
Which is why we're very interested in using social networking and media...
...along with the act of walking and picking.
But these two things have to go together.
Fallen Fruit is very interested in the idea of public space.
And what we're really particularly excited about...
...is the space between the alleys, the staircases,...
...and these spaces that kind of get overlooked.
And when you walk through a neighborhood and start looking at the world in a different way,...
...you see how much it really has to offer.